mean I don't understand what's so broken
see what bothers me is I feel like
there's something broken in women
because and I keep going back to like
it's not natural for us to behave this
way I don't feel like it's natural for
women to behave this way and like what
is broken that you can't even understand
now that a guy cares that three days ago
you're sleeping with someone else and
now you're in his bed that's nasty yeah
I I do feel like hypergamy is natural
like women like like monkey branching
and dating up that's been I went to an
art museum and there's paintings of
girls being hypergamous
red pill lens on an on a museum walk
yeah yeah Ally took me she took a new
Museum and she was showing me I'm like
oh my gosh